♪
>> WELL, GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
WASHINGTON, D.C. IS A
LAWMAKERS IN BOTH PARTIES
CAME TOGETHER IN GRAVE
AGREEMENT THAT IT WAS
UNFORTUNATE, UNACCEPTABLE
AND INDEED THREATENING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD REFER
TO POOR AND DANGEROUS
COUNTRIES AS IN EFFECT POOR
TACTICAL, OBVIOUSLY.
A WAY TO SCORE POLITICAL
ADVANTAGE BUT A GREAT DEAL
OF IT WAS ENTIRELY REAL.
IT WAS AUTHENTIC RAGE.
SO WHY ARE THE PEOPLE IN
CHARGE HYSTERICAL ABOUT
THIS?
IS IT BECAUSE TRUMP SAID
SOMETHING RACIALLY
INSENSITIVE?
LET'S SEE, JUST YESTERDAY
NANCY PELOSI DISMISSED THE
DACA NEGOTIATION BECAUSE
THERE WERE TOO MANY WHITE
PEOPLE INVOLVED AND MOST
PEOPLE HERE DIDN'T EVEN
NOTICE.
LEFT WING ATTACKS ON THE
BASIS OF RACE ARE NOW
COMMON.
VERY COMMON.
WOULD IT BE THEY FOUND IT
MAYBE.
BUT THEN THE LEFT HAS NO
PROBLEM BASHING HUGE PARTS
OF THIS COUNTRY.
DEPLORABLES.
[LAUGHTER]
RIGHT?
THE RACIST, SEXIST,
HOMOPHOBIC, XENOPHOBIC,
ISLAMOPHOBIC.
>> THEY CLING TO GUNS OR
RELIGION OR ANTIPATHY TOWARD
PEOPLE THAT AREN'T LIKE
THEM.
>> FIVE WHITE GUYS I CALL
[LAUGHTER]
I SAID YOU GOING TO OPEN A
HAMBURGER STAND NEXT OR
WHAT?
>> Tucker: THEY DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM DISMISSING ENTIRE
POPULATIONS.
SO WHAT IS THE REAL REASON
FOR THE PANIC YOU ARE
WATCHING RIGHT NOW ON CABLE
TELEVISION?
MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE TRUMP'S
REMARKS ARE FORCING
DON'T WANT TO HAVE.
HE DIDN'T DO IT ON PURPOSE.
WOULD RATHER NOT ANSWER LIKE
WHO EXACTLY ARE WE IMPORTING
INTO OUR COUNTRY AND HOW ARE
THEY DOING ONCE THEY GET
HERE?
ANSWER, OF COURSE, WELL THEY
ARE ALL VALEDICTORIANS AND
WAR HEROES AND WAY MORE
IMPRESSIVE AND WAY MORE
AMERICAN THAN YOU WILL EVER
BE SO SHUT UP.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TOLD.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE REQUIRED
TO BELIEVE.
WHAT IF IT'S NOT TRUE?
LAST YEAR THE U.S. ACCEPTED
23,000 PEOPLE FROM HAITI AND
127,000 FROM MEXICO.
IMMIGRATION FROM EL SALVADOR
SO BRISK ONE IN THREE EL
SALVADORIANS NOW LIVE IN THE
UNITED STATES HAS AMERICA
BECOME A BETTER COUNTRY AS A
RESULT?
HAS
MAS
MAYBE, MAYBE NOT.
MAYBE WE OUGHT TO TALK IT
THROUGH.
LEADERS WHO ACTUALLY CARED
ABOUT THEIR PEOPLE WOULD DO
EXACTLY THAT AND, YET, OUR
QUESTIONS.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM OF
SOUTH KOREA RELEASED
-UTH KOREA RELEASED
--TH KOREA RELEASED
--SO KOREA RELEASED
--SOUTOREA RELEASED
--SOUTHREA RELEASED
--SOUTH CA RELEASED
--SOUTH CARRELEASED
--SOUTH CAROLLEASED
--SOUTH CAROLINASED
--SOUTH CAROLINA RD
--SOUTH CAROLINA RELEASED A
STATEMENT TODAY HOW MOST OF
WASHINGTON THINKS ABOUT THE
SUBJECT.
IN A STATEMENT GRAHAM
DISMISSES THE IDEA THAT
AMERICA SHOULD EVEN THINK
ABOUT WHAT KIND OF PEOPLE IT
LET'S IN.
QUOTE:  I HAVE ALWAYS
DEFINED BY ITS PEOPLE BUT BY
ITS IDEALS, DIVERSITY HAS
AMERICA IS DEFINED BY ITS
OKAY.
SO WHAT ARE THOSE IDEALS?
IT MIGHT BE USEFUL TO KNOW
CONSIDERING HOW IMPORTANT
THEY ARE.
WELL, DIVERSITY IS OUR
STRENGTH IS THE ONLY ONE OUR
LEADERS SEEM TO AGREE ON.
THE LESS WE HAVE IN COMMON,
SOMEHOW THE STRONGER WE ARE.
IS THAT TRUE?
WE BETTER HOPE IT'S TRUE
BECAUSE WE ARE BETTING
EVERYTHING ON IT BUT THERE'S
A DEEPER PROBLEM WITH WHAT
SENATOR GRAHAM SAID.
QUOTE:  AMERICA IS NOT
DEFINED BY ITS PEOPLE.
REALLY?
WHAT DO ITS PEOPLE THINK
ABOUT THAT?
ARE THEY PLEASED TO LEARN
THEIR LEADERS CONSIDER THEM
MERELY A COMMODITY, A SET OF
INTERCHANGEABLE PARTS?
AMERICA'S ACTUAL PEOPLE WITH
THEIR ACTUAL FAMILIES AND
TOWNS AND TRADITIONS AND
HISTORY AND CUSTOMS MAY BE
SURPRISED TO LEARN THAT THEY
ARE IRRELEVANT TO THE
SUCCESS OR FAILURE OF WHAT
THEY IMAGINED WAS THEIR
COUNTRY.
ACCORDING TO LINDSEY GRAHAM,
YOU CAN TAKE OUR ENTIRE
POPULATION AND SWAP IT OUT
FOR 320 MILLION, I DON'T
KNOW, CHINESE OR INDIANS OR
AFRICANS ORCA MADIANS OR
PEOPLE FROM NEW ZEALAND AND
THE PLACE WOULD BE NO
DIFFERENT SO LONG AS THE
STARTING WITH THE U.S.
SENATE.
WOULD SOUTH CAROLINA GET THE
SAME REPRESENTATION FROM
SOMEONE RANDOMLY SELECTED
AS LINDSEY GRAHAM WOULD SAY
THE SENATE ISN'T DEFINED BY
ITS PEOPLE.
IT'S REALLY JUST AN IDEA.
AND AS SOON AS YOU START
DEFINING THINGS BY IDEAS
RATHER THAN INDIVIDUALS,
PEOPLE BECOME IRRELEVANT.
>>> JASON NICOLES IS A
PROFESSOR OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDIES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF MARYLAND AND
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: THIS ISN'T A
DEBATE FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
WHETHER OR NOT THE
PRESIDENTIAL IS VULGAR,
YEAH, HE IS.
IT'S A MUCH BIGGER DEBATE
ABOUT PEOPLE AND DO THEY
MATTER?
ARE PEOPLE INTERCHANGEABLE?
ARE ALL POPULATIONS THE
SAME?
IF I TOOK YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD
REPLACED THEM WITH OTHER
PEOPLE FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE,
WOULD THE NEIGHBORHOOD BE
THE SAME?
>> SO, FIRST THING, SINCE
YOU SAID IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE,
I DO WANT TO MENTION A
COUPLE OF PEOPLE.
I WOULD LIKE TO MENTION U.S.
ARMY SERGEANT MARIO NELSON
WHO GAVE HIS LIFE FOR THIS
>> Tucker: YEAH.
>> HE LEFT A 3-YEAR-OLD
I WANT TO GIVE MY
CONDOLENCES BUT HE GAVE HIS
LIFE FOR THIS COUNTRY.
MY FRIEND PAUL WHO -- HIS
VERY GOOD FRIEND WHILE HE
WAS IN AFGHANISTAN DIED IN A
ROCKET ATTACK.
SHE WAS BORN IN KENYA.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE
I SPENT PART OF THE DAY WITH
A TERRIFIC GUY FROM HAITI.
THERE ARE GREAT IMMIGRANTS
FROM HAITI AND EL SALVADOR
AND COUNTRIES YOU WOULDN'T
WANT TO LIVE.
IN THEY ARE GREAT PEOPLE.
I'M NOT CONTESTING THAT AT
ALL.
THE IDEA THAT ALL
POPULATIONS ARE THE SAME OR
PEOPLE OF AMERICA DON'T HAVE
A RIGHT TO DETERMINE WHO
COMES HERE OR IF YOU TAKE A
TON OF PEOPLE AND REPLACE
THEM WITH ANOTHER GROUP OF
PEOPLE, THEN EVERYTHING IS
EXACTLY THE SAME THE SAME
IDEA.
THAT'S JUST NOT TRUE.
RIGHT NOW, THEN WHY ARE WE
TRYING TO GET RID OF LARGE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
HERE?
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW.
BUT.
>> Tucker: LOOK, WE CAN PLAY
I KNOW AN IMPRESSIVE
IMMIGRANT GAME AND I WOULD
AGREE WITH YOU IN EVERY CASE
BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
IMPRESSIVE IMMIGRANTS BUT
THERE ARE ALSO A LOT OF
IMPRESSIVE NATIVE BORN
AMERICANS.
>> I AGREE TWO OF US RIGHT
HERE.
THEM.
>> SURE.
>> Tucker: THE IDEA THAT
IT'S SOMEHOW OUTRAGEOUS OR
BIGOTED TO SAY THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
COUNTRIES OR CULTURES.
>> WHAT IS OUTRAGEOUS AND
PLACES AND CALL THEM CRAP
HOLES AND, AGAIN, I'M GOING
TO EDIT MYSELF HERE BUT TO
CALL THEM CRAB HOLES.
LITIGATION IN COMMON OTHER
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY
IS THIS HE TALKS ABOUT WE
WANT PEOPLE FROM NIGERIA BUT
WE DON'T -- EXCUSE ME, WE
WANT PEOPLE FROM NORWAY BUT
NOT NIGERIA.
NIGERIA HAS A HIGHER G.D.P.
AFRICA.
>> Tucker: I MEAN, LOOK,
IT'S HARDLY RELEVANT TO THE
POINT.
>> IS IT?
>> Tucker: YOU ARE WRONG ON
THAT ONE POINT.
WORLD.
>> ACTUALLY THE G.D.P., THE
WAY I SAW IT WAS I THINK
IT'S --
>> Tucker: HERE'S THE POINT.
WE GET A TON MORE PEOPLE
FROM NIGERIA THAN WE DO FROM
NORWAY.
>> SURE.
BECAUSE PEOPLE FROM NORWAY
DON'T HAVE TO LEAVE THERE NO
HEALTHCARE UP TO THE AGE OF
REALLY INTERESTED IN HELPING
AMERICA, YOU WOULD WANT THE
MOST IMPRESSIVE PEOPLE YOU
FROM NORWAY.
SOME WOULD BE HAVE FROM
JAPAN TO MOVE HERE.
YOU WOULD RATE THEM ON THE
BASIS OF HOW IMPRESSIVE THEY
WERE.
YOU WOULD NOT SAY THE FIRST
PEOPLE TO GET HERE HAVE
RELATIVES HERE.
YOU DON'T RUN YOUR COLLEGE
THAT WAIT A MINUTE HARVARD
DOESN'T LET THE FIRST 7,000
SALVADORIANS THAT APPLY.
WHY DON'T WE DO THAT?
>> WE DO DO THAT.
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU SAID
ABOUT NIGERIA, THE LAST TIME
HIGHER MEDIAN INCOME AND
MORE EDUCATED THAN NATIVE
BORN AMERICANS WHEN THEY GET
HERE NIGERIAN IMMIGRANTS.
THEY ARE NOT GOING BACK TO
THEIR HUTS AS THE PRESIDENT
>> Tucker: ACTUALLY, IF YOU
ARE CLAIMING THAT WE ARE
KNOW MUCH ABOUT OUR SYSTEM
WHICH GIVES OVERWHELMING
PRIORITY TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE
RELATIVES HERE.
BEING RELATED TO SOMEONE IS
NOT A QUALIFICATION IT'S AN
ACCIDENT.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT THAT'S
NOT A CRITERION THAT APPLE
USES WHEN IT HIRES PEOPLE.
IF YOU REALLY CARED ABOUT
ARE.
>> AGAIN, I THINK SERGEANT
NELSON WAS THE BEST.
HE CAME HERE, HE SACRIFICED
HIS LIFE FOR THIS COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
I'M NOT CONTESTING THAT.
>> SO I'M NOT.
>> PEOPLE WHO COME HERE WHO
WORK EXTREMELY HARD.
>> Tucker: THEY DO.
>> SOME OF THEM DO VERY
WELL.
>> Tucker: WE DO.
AND WE ALSO HAVE PEOPLE WHO
COME HERE AND DON'T DO WELL.
THE POINT.
>> AND THERE ARE NATIVE BORN
PEOPLE THE SAME WAY.
>> Tucker: THIS COUNTRY
BELONGS TO AMERICAN
CITIZENS, PERIOD.
OKAY?
SO THAT'S WHERE WE START.
IT WOULD GO OUT OF BUSINESS.
TO SUGGEST THAT PEOPLE WHO
RAN COUNTRY OR COLLEGE
DIDN'T CARE OF THE
WEREN'T TRYING TO FIND THE
BEST.
WHY DON'T WE DO THAT?
>> AGAIN, I THINK OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM CERTAINLY
NEEDS WORK.
IT NEEDS SOME CHANGES.
PROBLEM HERE.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
I KIND OF MISSED THAT PART?
>> ARE YOU MISSING THAT
PART?
>> Tucker: THE PRESIDENT
SAID WE SHOULD HAVE A MERIT
BEARED SYSTEM.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID.
CRAP HOLES, YOU KNOW, AND
WAS REFERRING TO THE AFRICAN
CONTINENT.
>> Tucker: NO.
HE SAID OUR IMMIGRANT.
LOOK.
>> -TO-DEFEND.
>> YOU ARE CORRECTING HIS
STATEMENT.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT HERE TO
CORRECT WHAT HE SAID.
I'M HERE TO MAKE THE CASE
FOR ACTING ON BEHALF OF OUR
COUNTRY WITH A MERIT BASED
STATES AND YOU SAID THOSE
THINGS, WE COULD SIT HERE
AND HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
THAT.
I WOULD BE 100 PERCENT OPEN
TO IT.
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> THE PROBLEM IS YOU ARE
SITTING HERE AND MAKING AN
ARGUMENT THAT THE PRESIDENT
HASN'T MADE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S FINE.
LOOK, I THINK AS A GENERAL
MATTER WE PAY WAY TOO MUCH
ATTENTION TO THE BRAIN
DROPPINGS OF THE PRESIDENT.
>> HE IS THE PRESIDENT.
YOU HAVE TO PAY ATTENTION TO
WHAT HE SAYS.
WHITE HOUSE HAS ISSUED ITS
PLANS WHICH HAVE BEEN
CHAIN MIGRATION, MAKE THIS A
MERIT BASED SYSTEM, END THE
DIVERSITY LOITER AND INSTALL
EVERIFY.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THOSE
THE OTHER THINGS THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
>> THE DEVIL RAYS RIGHT NOW
HAS INCREASED THE AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO DEPORT AND IS TALKING
ABOUT LEAVING 800,000 YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO HAVE LIVED HERE
LIKE MY FRIEND NANCY, THE
AGE OF 3, TRYING TO KEEP
GETTING EDUCATION.
ENROLL ILLEGALLY AND TART
TAKING CLASSES FNCHES
SOMEBODY IS HERE BY THE AGE
OF 3 AND DIDN'T CHOOSE TO BE
HERE AND THAT'S ALL THEY
KNOW YES THAT SIM MORAL.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO DEPORT DACA
CITIZENS.
PEOPLE HERE COMMITTING
CRIMES GUY THEY HAVE TO BE
HERE.
>> SINCE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THE PEOPLE
ANSWERED ANY OF MY
QUESTIONS.
>> I WANT TO TREAT THE
COUNTRY WITH THE LOVE AND
RESPECT YOU TREAT YOUR
COLLEGE WITH.
TO ITS VALUES.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
OTHER COUNTRIES.
>> ONE OF THE GREATEST
SYMBOLS OF FREEDOM IN THIS
COUNTRY, OF COURSE, IS THE
POEM THAT TALKS ABOUT THE
HUDDLED MASSES.
IT TALKS ABOUT BRINGING
STAND FOR AS A NATION.
>> Tucker: WHAT WE STAND FOR
IS PROTECTING OUR OWN PEOPLE
BECAUSE IT'S THEIR COUNTRY.
WE ARE AMERICANS, THAT'S THE
WHOLE POINT OF A GOVERNMENT.
I DON'T THINK OUR INTERESTS
ARE BEING LOOKED OUT FOR
FIRST.
I JUST DON'T.
>> I WOULD DISAGREE WITH
THAT I AGREE WITH YOU THAT I
THINK THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
NOT ALWAYS LOOKING OUT FOR